AGENTS NAB HIM THERE IS NOTHING
THE D.A. CAN DO ABOUT IT.
>> Bret: THANKS.
THE PRESIDENT'S DECISION ABOUT
TARRIFS COMES JUST DAYS BEFORE A
CRUCIAL CONGRESSIONAL SPECIAL
ELECTION IN THE HEART OF STEEL
COUNTRY.
HERE'S THE REPORT FROM
PITTSBURGH.
>> [APPLAUDING].
>> THOSE PENNSYLVANIA STEEL
WORKER WENT TO THE WHITE HOUSE
TO BACK PRESIDENT TRUMP'S NEW
TARRIFS, THE UNITED STEEL
WORKER'S UNION IS NOT BACKING
HIS CHOICE FOR CONGRESS RICK
SACCONE WHO IS FIGHTING TO FILL
A VACANT SEAT.
THEY RALLIED FOR DEMOCRAT CONOR
LAMB THIS AFTERNOON.
>> CONOR LAMB BECAUSE HE IS FOR
THE WORKING MAN.
PROTECTING SOCIAL SECURITY AND
MEDICARE.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE LOOKING FOR.
>> THIS MARINE VETERAN AND
FORMER FOLLOW PROSECUTOR PULLED
IN SUPPORT FROM CARPENTERS TO
GOAL MINERS AND IS ENDORSED BY
THE LARGEST FEDERATION OF LABOR
UNIONS IN THE STATE.
LONG TIME UNION ALLY JOE BIDEN
COMPAINED WITH LAMB AND
KELLYANNE CONWAY STUMPED FOR
SACCONE BILLING HIM AS THE RIGHT
CANDIDATE FOR WORKERS.
>> WITH RESPECT TO THE PEOPLE
WHO MOTIVATED DONALD TRUMP TO
RUN FOR PRESIDENT IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
THE STEEL WORKERS.
THE COAL MINERS AND ALL OF THOSE
EMPLOYEES.
>> SACCONE WON THE ENDORSEMENT
OF THE NATIONAL FEDERATION OF
INDEPENDENT BUSINESS AND ALIGNED
HIMSELF WITH THE PRESIDENT'S
AGENDA.
HE HAS AIR FORCE SERVICE AND
YEARS OF INTERNATIONAL BUSINESS.
>> THERE IS A STARK CONTRAST
BETWEEN MYSELF AND MY OPPONENT.
HE IS ON THE OPPOSITE SIDE OF
ALL ISSUES.
I AM THE MAN FOR THIS JOB.
I AM QUALIFIED.
OVER 40 YEARS OF LIFE EXPERIENCE
IN EDUCATION AND THE MILTARY AND
GOVERNMENT AND INTERNATIONAL
BUSINESS.
IT'S AN UNMATCHED RESUME
COMPARED TO CONOR LAMB WHO HAS
ALMOST NO LIFE EXPERIENCE.
>> THIS ELECTION MAY TEST THE
POWER OF ORGANIZED LABOR AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE WILL COME TO PENNSYLVANIA